foreign
this is your Tech news briefing for
Monday March 13th I'm Julie Chang for
the Wall Street Journal filling in for
Zoe Thomas
for decades Silicon Valley Bank was a
pillar for the venture capital and
startup Community then on Friday in less
than two days it collapsed and the
government stepped in to take it over
investors and startups spent the weekend
scrambling to help their portfolio
companies find new sources of cash in
the crypto World it led a major
stablecoin to break its Peg to the US
dollar and by Sunday night Federal
Regulators were rolling out emergency
measures to prevent a broader banking
crisis including steps to backstop all
depositors and taking control of another
bank Signature Bank
svb's fall marks the second biggest bank
failure in U.S history after Washington
Mutual during the 2008 financial crisis
so what happened with svb and what kind
of Ripple effects could this have in the
tech sector and Beyond here with us to
sort through this is wsj finance editor
Charles Farrell hi Charles thank you for
joining us pleasure to be here so
Charles for those of us who may be less
familiar with Silicon Valley Bank can
you tell us a little bit about it as
well as what role it played in the whole
Venture Capital startup ecosystem
sure so Silicon Valley bank is in some
respects a very conventional bank that
happens to be in Silicon Valley it does
things that normal bank would do it
takes in deposits it makes loans it
helps its customers process payments and
payroll and all kinds of other stuff
what is unconventional about Silicon
Valley Bank is How Deeply it is tied to
one specific industry so it's very much
a bank that's widely used by Tech
startups and by the Venture capitalists
and the private Equity companies that
invest in them so Silicon Valley Bank
had a really tightly knit customer base
it would do lots of specialized things
that would help tech companies startups
and the funds that invested in them and
because it was good at that it drew in a
lot a lot a lot of people in Silicon
Valley as as customers can you walk us
through exactly what happened here why
did svb collapse so on Wednesday Silicon
Valley Bank made a pretty astonishing
announcement which is that it would need
to sell a bunch of Securities that it
held so these are assets they it has
mostly bonds treasury bonds and other
things and it would need to sell them
and it would take a loss selling them
and the reason that it needed to do that
was that a bunch of depositors were
pulling their money out and it needed to
replenish that lost money so it had to
sell things that it owned in order to
satisfy all of these withdrawal requests
this is not a thing that bank investors
or the markets or depositors want to
hear because that is how Bank runs get
started and that can become a
self-fulfilling spiral and that is what
happened so once they said hey we need
to sell these things in order to satisfy
depositors they attempted to try to do
some things to short people's confidence
they said with an investor lined up to
bring in some fresh Capital we're going
to do all these different things to make
ourselves solid they set all this on
Wednesday evening but Thursday morning
it was very clear that neither the
markets nor their own depositors thought
that would be sufficient and Thursday
the deposit flight accelerated and in
fact kind of fed by the fact that it was
such a tightly knit community that it
served tell everybody in Silicon Valley
even knows everybody else in Silicon
Valley and they all talk and they hear
that this guy is taking money out so
they take their money out as well and it
accelerated through Thursday and they
were unable to complete overnight
Thursday to Friday the capital raise the
new money that they were trying to get
by Friday morning and on Friday morning
they called their quits and said we're
done and what did that run on Silicon
Valley Bank look like can you give us a
sense for what startup Founders were
doing while this is all going down as an
example there's a startup in California
called Ruth health and one of our
reporters was talking to one of the
co-founders who said on Thursday she got
an email from an investor in Ruth health
and said the Investor's email said take
your money out and so one of the other
co-founders Audrey Wu began trying to
take money out as as quickly as she
could trying to make different transfers
of different amounts whatever she could
get out then the website crashed and she
was unable to get back in so that's the
sort of thing that was happening on
Thursday when customers oftentimes told
by either their investors or other
customers or their peers in the industry
time to get your money out all rushed to
try to do it at once this collapse of
svb was very set in have we ever seen
anything like this before I mean there
have been plenty of Bank collapses in
the history of the United States but
this is a very fast one we haven't seen
one like this in a while I mean the
financial crisis there were some pretty
big ones obviously but even in the
financial crisis there was a little bit
more of a drawn out process the speed
with which this one came apart was
indeed really fast now we also saw
Signature Bank get taken over by
Regulators over the weekend what kind of
an impact could all this have on Silicon
Valley and Beyond that's very hard to
say investors and depositors and people
have money at these banks are trying to
assess that now
um that's really the question of the
moment is if this is the tip of the
iceberg how deep is the iceberg or is it
just a a kind of one-off thing it's not
quite a one-off because a similar thing
happened at silvergate which is a crypto
Focus bank but is it a one or two or
three banks that have very very
different models than everybody else or
is it actually a wider thing and that as
yet is not clear wsj Finance editor
Charles Farrell thank you so much for
your time today my pleasure Julie and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
but a quick reminder before we close out
the show we want to hear your questions
about generative artificial intelligence
AI programs like chat GPT Microsoft's
new Bing search or mid-journey we're
going to answer them on an upcoming
episode do you want to know how these
kinds of AI programs work but they're
capable of or maybe with the latest wave
of AI developments could mean for how we
live our lives leave us a voicemail with
your AI question at
415-439-6482 you can also email us a
voice recording at tnb
wsj.com we look forward to hearing from
you I'm Julie Chang for the Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
foreign